Hello, I'm the Nostalgia Critic.
I remember it so you don't have to!
Are you sick to death yet of CGI?
Nobody would blame you, it's practically
impossible to see a movie that
doesn't have some form of CGI -
aka Computer Generated Imagery - in it.
And it's not just movies! It's
in our commercials, our phones
It's even in our breakfast cereals!
And the consensus from
people seems to be the same:
"We're sick of it, it's everywhere.
We want a little bit more variety!"
So, how come it keeps popping
up all over the place?
And should we just flat-out put a stop to it?
Well, the first thing to
analyze is why people are
getting annoyed by the
use of it to begin with.
Because, before, people
couldn't get enough of it.
When they saw it bring ground-breaking effects to life in
movies like "Jurassic Park" and
"Terminator 2", people were hypnotized.
They never saw anything like it.
And even to this day,
these effects still
hold up pretty well!
Part of that is because it was
the filmmakers' first time
using it, and so they felt they
had a lot more to prove and
mix the effects with a
lot of other elements.
For example, there's motion
capture after motion capture
after motion capture of
Robert Patrick as the T-1000.
Which would most likely would be
filmed in just one shot today
just to get an idea of
the lighting and movement.
On top of that, not every effect
was CGI. Any time the T-1000 was injured,
it was always a practical effect
on the set. Yeah, that's an
animatronic right there.
Pretty damn impressive, huh? The
same thing with Jurassic Park.
The dinosaurs, half the time, were CGI.
But the other
half were life size robots
that were right there
in front of the actors.
Like many effects in the past,
this worked effectively
because they were constantly
using different methods
to fool the eye. The more
variation you use, the more
difficult it'll be for the eye
to get used to the effect,
and thus spot it.
But then, somewhere down the
line, we got too fucking greedy.
And, I guess really, it's no big surprise.
You could suddenly
see things and do things you
couldn't have done before.
You could get shots or
perform stunts that still
look cool, but didn't
have to endanger anybody
and it was usually at half the cost.
But, because it was used so often,
we naturally trained our
eyes to spot it easier.
When we first saw
"Jurassic Park", we didn't know
what was computer
and what was a robot.
But now, because we've been so exposed
to it, it's a little easier to spot.
And because computers work
in a way where you can
just take an existing
program and add onto it,
less time is needed to create a
creature from the ground up.
You can't just take
something like a ninja turtle
and build a Jabba
the Hutt out of it.
However with computers, the lighting
and movement of a dinosaur can now be
reproduced in a totally different
monster in a totally different movie.
The idea being if it worked in one film,
logically it should work in the next.
But like I said before, people started
to catch on to these patterns.
And they were becoming
more and more noticeable.
When you look back on films
like "(Who Framed) Roger Rabbit", you
ask yourself, "How did
they make those cartoons,
that were obviously drawn, still
somehow seemed three-dimensional?"
Well, that's because they did a
test shot for every take they did
to get an idea where the
lighting was going to be,
so they could see how the camera capture
it and reproduce it as best as they could.
But here, we have programs
that can do the math for us
and figure out where the lighting would be.
But the reason this doesn't always fool
people is because in reality,
light is not always going to fall where the
mathematical equation says it will.
Whether it be the environment,
the camera angle, whatever
there's always going to be
something a little different about
real life that a computer
is not going to catch.
Why do I know that this Yoda was
really there and this Yoda wasn't?
Because the one that was there had the
light hit it in it's own unique way
because this Yoda is an illusion
in that he's an animated puppet.
But this Yoda is not
only an animated puppet,
but an animated puppet
that's not really there.
So now you have to deal with
two filters of reality -
two illusions going on at the same time.
And when there's two illusions
going on as opposed to one,
that makes it a lot easier for
people to spot what's false.
Now there are times where CG
can still look very realistic.
I mean, my god, Gollum from "The Two
Towers" still looks fucking unbelievable.
Once in a while he looked a little
phony, but for the most part,
it looked and felt like he was
honest-to-god really there.
And that's because - he was really there.
Andy Serkis who provided the voice
also got dressed up in costume and
shot the scenes with the other actors.
So not only did the animators
have on-set movement
and on-set performances,
but they also had
an on-set model that
they could capture the
life from that was really
there in the scene.
And on top of that, the guy
that got to do the textures
for the skin wasn't a computer
guy, he was a make-up guy.
In fact, he was originally designing
a puppet/costume for Gollum.
But, when they decided to do the
CG route, they taught him the program
because they figured he
knew what texture should look like.
And he did! And it looks unbelievable!
So this wasn't just all
computer programmers that
were putting this together,
it was a variety of artists
who all knew how to do different illusions
in order to bring the major one to life.
But, that's pretty ballsy saying
computer animators do nothing
but type in a program, I know
there's a lot more than that.
You'll have to fool people
to thinking something
is in front of you from
literally nothing.
But like I said before,
because it's an illusion
of an illusion - convincing an audience
of something that's fictional exists
while also convincing them it's
in the scene, when it's not -
- it's harder to fool people.
However, that's when the accepting
of the illusion comes in.
You don't watch movies like "Lion
King" or "Beauty and the Beast" with
the idea that what we're seeing
in front of us is really there.
We see it, because it has a story
and characters that we enjoy.
And we give in to the illusion more
because we know there are benefits to it -
like how expressive it
can be, how artistically
pleasing it can be and
so on and so forth.
I think that is why CG animated
movies have caught on so much.
Because now, it's reversed.
Rather than CGI being an illusion
of an illusion, in the world of
animation, it's the closest thing
to looking realistic that we have.
You always come across those
people who say they can't
watch cartoons, because
they know it's not real,
they know it's a bunch of
drawings and nothing else.
But CGI has helped audiences like that
because even though they're clearly animated,
they look more three-dimensional
and realistic.
So now, the hand drawn style is
the illusion of the illusion.
And as much as I adored 2D animation, there's
no doubt that 3D animation looks more
like real life and thus is probably going
to be more acceptable to wider audiences
and has been for the past several years.
Granted, when CG animation first started,
it was piss-poor, with the faces
seeming like lifeless puppets, because -
let's face it - that's what they were.
But as it evolved, CG animation has
managed to capture almost as much,
if not just as much, emotion as the
classic hand-drawn animated films.
This accepting of the illusion has also led
to some great imagery in live action films.
"Sin City", as well as a lot of of
Robert Rodriguez movies, clearly
have most of their world in very
fake looking CGI backgrounds.
But they're so stylized and so
artistically pleasing that we don't care.
We just love looking at them.
This is usually a risk, seeing
how most audiences want to
believe as much as possible that
what they're seeing is real
But still, films like "300"
have found an audience,
despite our awareness that
it's obviously not there.
And speaking of not there, that's
another great effect CGI can pull off -
getting rid of the strings.
That is to say, we've all
seen puppets, stop-motion
animation or other green
screen effects before.
And you're almost always aware that that's
what you're watching with that pesky line
because the lighting in two different
locations never quite matched up.
But now, CGI can blend that
line out almost flawlessly.
Allowing two different
elements from two totally
different rooms to seem like
they're in the same one.
As laughingly noticeable some of the
effects in "Forrest Gump" are today
we're still pretty blown away by
the absence of Gary Sinise's legs
There's also no trouble believing that
the headless horseman really is headless.
So, maybe CGI is better at convincing
that something is not there rather
than something is, and there's definitely
a lot of benefits to it after all.
So, should we be sick of CGI?
In some respects,
but I don't think that means
stop it altogether.
CGI is great for creating
worlds and illusions,
but it shouldn't probably
be used for every part
of that world or every
element of those illusions.
Every story is going to
tell itself differently,
and if the idea is to be like
a magic trick where you know
it's an illusion, but you
appreciate the showmanship anyway,
CGI is going to be great.
But if the idea is to tell a story where the
illusion is supposed to completely fool you,
then it's probably wiser to mix it up with
models, puppets and other practical effects.
As an art form, it's come a long way
and opened up all sorts of
avenues and visual wonders,
but people forget, how
many avenues can be opened
up by combining old
tricks with new tricks
and can often create much
more powerful illusions.
So, CGI shouldn't go away or being
criticized for all that its done
but it should be
acknowledged as only one
method that could be used
in creating an effect -
not just for the sake of
variety and creativity, but
because the common person
is just catching onto it.
Because the more a magician repeats his
trick over and over and over again, the
more likely an audience is going to be to
catch onto it and beg for something more.
Especially if that magician is CG.
I'm the Nostalgia Critic, I
remember it so you don't have to!
Doug Walker here, I have some
important things to say.
Premium Access is back
until the end of December.
It is $40 for lifetime access.
You can download Nostalgia Critics, Bum
Reviews, Video Game Confessions and more.
Also -
Autograph charity drive photos would be available for $17.50.
Only 200 would be available,
so may the fastest 200 win.
Two new metal prints are available.
They're both awesome.
There is 125 each,
buy them now.
DVDs of "To Boldly Flee" are briefly
back in stock you must buy them now.
We have also discovered extra signed
photos from the anniversary specials.
These are in extremely limited quantities.
I have not been wearing pants
throughout this entire video.
Oh, you want me to prove it?!